the Japanese tomato superhero
good morning so today's another day in
Tokyo and this morning we finally got a
10:00 sleep in because we've been waking
up like at 5:00 every morning but now we
slept until 7:00 roko guess oh right now
we're on our way to go eat some bomb
katsu and reset it relax I'm really
hungry I pick a still with Joe he's
gonna be back with us tonight after
dinner I miss my baby yeah yeah
read her juku - cool
because those people are so many people
today I feel like today watching is way
more packed than it should be because
first of the weekend second the holiday
season so everybody's trying to shop for
Christmas I just think it's interesting
that it's the first time we've seen
people wear colors like in terms of my
clothing other than black and gray is
invading you can literally see it if you
look down the street black me gray
everybody trying Thrones today though
I'm seeing a lot more color a lot more
excitement and faces do that cute ass
actually my favorite color you feel
better yes
that's one of sweat balls you're [ __ ]
crazy where we are all in winter jackets
and Bart needs to be and his wife beater
that's one of us heart moving I just my
skin's cold but the best of Makati your
skin is cold
yeah that's your husband you married
that guy
she put a shirt on I want to mess with
you there at the kudzu spot a cute
little restaurant yeah I'm starving
oh good authentic we got a to crush
result you know the floor
we are here now at tonkatsu my sin which
I'm guessing is a name of a spot oh
there we go
what are you gonna get Brendan they're
worth it have you been here then we've
got our token down your dumb
stereotypical Asians love the stairs
they're not afraid to stare and they
don't they don't think that's wrong I
guess we're traveling with two people
topstitching Lee that stick out one
you're a black man Josh oh they're
perfect and he gets a lot of stares
because for being black obviously it's
just I don't love black in which a man
so obviously didn't get a lot of stares
the other person that's doing a lot of
stairs though we all get scarred I
wasn't about to go through the half
taxes in Japan the Mafia
so kusa Yakuza members have tattoos and
so he's walking around in tattoos and
it's all one he had sure Lessman for two
he's watching it work awesome talking
like 10 notches louder than everyone
else
Josh walks in he gets all the stairs
we're going to order moment Bart walks
and Barbie intercepts all the stairs
everyone staring that far Josh isn't as
desire to the Japanese people here as
Bart is Bart [ __ ] buff as Asian doing
tattoos just actually pretty normal
looking at su-35 yeah Jesse god damn it
thanks Lisa it looks like cats it's a
80s you cat food hey Carl while we're LA
me so I ran in how you do this so you
take the cap off of your pork belly me
so horny me so what the hell I'm like
lifting the whole bowl up high like the
food big bomb diggity
is it better than curry house cuz he
hired to this standard for you with
curry house like curry house walk walk
yeah I don't know I was more more of a
curry house than you bro but I'd rather
have this graph any day curry house is a
franchise great place very houses the
house that mix fairy know when it comes
to food ignore everything that comes out
of my mouth
cuz I'm not a big person so my food take
co strainer at say I might be the only
one here that doesn't like what I'm
eating as much as everybody else likes
it
there's not a whole lot of pork flavor
it's the textures on point though was
the batter and the frying and then the
moisture of the pork is very very good
but it just lacks a lot of flavor in my
opinion it all I taste is little batter
oil and sauce
finished alright we've walked over to
the street where alley looking place
next to Brandon actually Brandon I think
you'd be really good friends with my
brother if my brothers really invested
by plunky loves billionaire boys club
guys no one were you gonna eat in my is
that looks like instead of shoelaces
they have this to take your shoes
it could be wrong though it doesn't see
it doing anything oh there we go it is
it is a shoelace a nerd thing that's
cool I'll choose to have it is the way
in the future
oh my God look at this tiny little
frigerator oh it's so cute that freaking
tiny little refrigerators making me want
to put my shirt right now that's too
cute like all their structures are here
just goes up up up
all right we are now at a barbecue
restaurant we walked in thinking we're
gonna eat some pork some B's and chicken
but the only meat that they serve just
so happens to be let me show you this
picture what is this animal right here
yes a horse and they only serve horse
meat half the crew left more than half
the crew left the only people are left
with us right now is rendang I'll you
just want anything just about same here
so a little nervous sexer there's this
part of me that kind of thought that's a
little gross
I don't know sure if I could eat a horse
but it winter in Rome and it does and
David brought up a pretty good one it
does smell fantastic in here and so
we're gonna try it oh my god okay what's
just what's happening right now Brendan
what we're about to eat some horse
sashimi anyways where the horse meat is
so this is the neck meat I'm not sure
wouldn't select this horse fat as United
or fat
that's our figure eight off the neck
this is oh this is a fast rail for the
next leg first thank you oh [ __ ] got
real do it Chuck I'm gonna adventurers
eater but this is scary even what listen
we can do this we're gonna get in a
couple more beers so ask me
my god well I miss him Oh Sami and
putting as much Misaki as I can I
already look you're here oh [ __ ] let me
go all right horse me here we go
horse me you've been good
tell me that's not bad that's pretty
good I'm good
fortunately is really good it's like
surprisingly good
there's night is that gamey I was
expected be like kind of lamb or goat
yeah but it's not would be next piece
the sauce is good though this sauce is
like sweet it really pops out the flavor
of the meat with this texture too is
very tender you know you would think or
I mean maybe it's separate specific cuts
they have true but you wait I thought or
should be like huh I really excited
about this one because this one is
marvelous whap even the marbling I'm a
fan of a bad I come back oh my life in
music lumbar Bart Martin and remission
down dude because they were down but
they be easy they felt compelled for the
girls they they left and I'm the [ __ ]
boyfriend that didn't go with him
I've done this is like the fat from the
back of the neck of the horse there we
go jeez there's number horse 1000 I have
the tech you're like quit this is better
than sushi this is better than sushi me
this is better than a horse that I love
it may I don't know how healthy it is
not it it's [ __ ] good though I'm
guessing we're gonna we're gonna do the
grilling stuff next horse d5 come on
very juicy
the meat fat cap on Illinois sauce oh my
god
wash me flavors off now I'm at amount
I'm not sure if I'm a big fan of the
chewiness but how could you run this all
day hey it's so good we just got to get
horse another name you know if you don't
call beef cow or gonna call pork pit
what a horse we call horse meat all
disease better than beef that's all you
need to know when I'll see you all right
tonight we are gonna go see robot robot
restaurant we're gonna see robots and
girls dance and fight or something I
don't even know what's going on but this
street is [ __ ] crazy
we're going in
oh this place is crazy
I know magic door opens I think ever
been anywhere like this I said
my
rock'n'roll Daft Punk is here skills
cost your records no frills here's your
bill my ease back
who the [ __ ] thinks of this who thought
with his concept Jesus look at that
stepping all over them whoa it's crazy
are here are you excited to get here can
you hear me I tried looking for like one
tiny inch bass that wasn't covered in
madness and I couldn't find it I beat
down like one room in my head like this
yeah I can't help but wonder who the
[ __ ] out of this [ __ ] I get it
but really you got my head are you guys
excited
what would you guys think of the walk
down that staircase oh and she's in
tears though cuz I heard she don't
really are a pretty excited about it is
because Japan's offer some pretty
bizarre stuff this guy again
okay this Japan's known for some pretty
bizarre stuff and I think this is the
first bizarre thing we're doing on this
trip know what whole cafe au revoir I
mean compared to this I mean of course
part of this I don't think anything else
sleeps performance
but yeah it's the cameras focus on song
I know and then a [ __ ] camera can
focus on anything my Tommy
turn away for you guys mostly on back
hey what's going on I don't feel like
that was amazing
where'd you think of that